so black panther wakanda forever is now
out on Disney plus and because of this I
thought I'd revisit the movie to point
out some of the best Easter eggs hidden
details and things you missed in it
these are things I haven't seen pointed
out in other videos and there's some of
the smallest details in the movie that
you might have missed when watching it
and the film centers around shuri taking
up the mantle of the Black Panther in
the wake of her brother t'challa's death
Chadwick boseman's passing left a big
hole in the franchise the actor's
real-life death influenced the film in
several ways beyond the obvious plot
points the creative team left a tribute
to the actor in the movie and this
happens when Everett Ross is sprung from
the prison transport as he's being
driven along the road we can make out
the license plate and this reads cb112
976 the CB actually stands for Chadwick
Boseman with the numbers representing
his birthday on the 29th of November
1976. now the idea of grief is laced
throughout the film and it's actually a
major part of phase four Wonder had to
deal with the loss of her children and
vision black widow and with Elena green
Natasha Xiang Chi was changed by the
loss of his mother and no way home deals
with the death of anime spoiler alert
few characters you might not think are
similar though arcor and shuri in the
opening of the movie we watch her
praying to Bass to save her brother and
this is similar to gore praying to his
God to save his daughter neither of
these prayers Iran said and thus both
become angry and bitter for some time
Bast of course also appeared in love and
thunder during the god scene and
alongside them we saw the Mind God ketzo
cuddle now it's devastating that shuri
couldn't be with her brother in his
final moments as she was trying to save
him rather than accepting his Fate
ashiri has always been more signs based
rather than believing in Gods in
religion in the comics this I actually
had a lot of repercussions and during
black panther Issue 4 from 2009 she was
denied the mantle because of her
arrogance when shiri's mother Amanda is
killed this pushes her further down a
path of anger and both this side and her
arrogance are why she meets killmonger
on the ancestral plane this also happens
in the throne room which is of course
also where her mother died she even
begins where Amanda was submerged in the
water just beside the platform now he
watches this is set on fire mirroring
the burning of the herb God in the first
black panther film however it has a
deeper meaning as Shiri says it won't be
this close I'll burn
to be the world
everyone in it in the scene we can also
see Sherry wearing her funeral robes
showing how this idea has carried across
to this moment like on the end of the
film he watches her mind races and
reverses the water the point that she
sees her mother this is who the
character actually wanted to see on the
ancestral plane and this finally gives
her the wisdom of her ancestors to stop
this self-destructive cycle now upon
gaining her power she hits a mannequin
across the room and this is something
that her brother did in the first movie
when visiting her lab like Sherry in the
comics killmonger actually made a
synthetic curve which further pushed him
down the road of taking the secret of
power of wakanda and using it elsewhere
he eventually gave this to Kevin Cole
and the character ended up becoming the
white tiger now in this opening scene we
can hear shuri's AI whose voiced by
Trevor Noah though this AI appeared in
the first movie it's clearly had some
upgrades and in Infinity War sure he was
able to map vision's brain when trying
to remove the Mind Stone I think she's
applied some of this to her own
technology and the visualization of the
AI itself is even yellow just like the
Mind stone is the AI is named griot and
this is named after a West African
Storyteller which sure he actually met
in the comics when visiting the
ancestral plane ashiri ends up holding
the helmet in front of her at one point
and this is actually not a surey issue 2
from 2018. now the funeral procession
sees everyone wearing white and the
first Black Panther movie was coming hot
off the back of Civil War in which the
king died and we actually saw this
reflected in the film when t'challa
returned to the kingdom we saw both his
mother and sister wearing white and this
was because they were grieving for
t'chuka beside t'challa's coffin we can
also catch his Spear and shield and
these are what the character fought with
during his trial in the first movie
speaking of Spears and shields the talo
Kenyans fight with them throughout the
film and at the end of the movie we can
see they use turtle shells as a defense
at the funeral we see a mural for him
and the text around this reads the
panther king forever lives in us he's
now with the ancestors everyone does the
wakan in salute and is actually means
love in American Sign Language the idea
of Crossing is even seen in the two
ships that fly across the sky and they
create an ax just behind the ship now
they used to Charlie's helmet from Civil
War and this was picked for an important
reason to Charles Ark and that revolved
around him getting Vengeance for his
father's death much like how sure he
does in this film both decide to not let
Vengeance consume them in the end and
this is the line that's echoed at the
end of the film Legends has consumed you
he's consuming them
letting it consume me
Vengeance has consumed us
we cannot let it consume our people
be sure he wears face paint to create
dots and hair and this is something that
she also did in the previous movie when
fighting against killmonger this later
gets incorporated into her mask and
culturally they were worn by the Surrey
tribe which is also where the
character's name originates from at the
funeral you might also notice that
there's statues of bashenga along with
his wife bashenga was the first black
panther and in front of the pair we can
also catch two Panther statues gods and
ancestral lace throughout the film and
this is seen in several facets of the
movie originally in the comics Neymar
was Atlantean however this was changed
to talocan so that the character
wouldn't clash with DC's Aquaman talocan
actually has roots in our own world and
talocan with an L after the first T was
believed to be a Paradise by the Aztecs
he thought that those that died by
Drowning were absorbed by it and it was
ruled over the rain God Shaq who gets
mentioned by them all later on now after
the funeral and title sequence we cut to
the UN we find out that Franz was
attempting to take the vibranium and
they actually colonized parts of Haiti
where we learn the care has fled to here
she's raised the sun in secret and we
learn that he's actually going under the
name Toussaint Tucson is actually named
after a Haitian General called Tucson
lavator who fought against the French
for Independence this thematically ties
her back to this opening and it's
possible that what kind of knew this due
to their spy Network in the first film
killmonger said that they had spies in
every nation across the globe and they
could have infiltrated the French
government to learn of this attack now
you might also catch to San Elion and
he's with the three children that go to
a Monday anyway back at the UN we also
meet the US Secretary of State played by
Richard Schiff we actually know who the
president is at this point because of
the cast listing for secret Invasion and
he'll be called president ritzen this
name actually pops up later on in a news
ticket and we can see the text written
signs trade act with new Asgard a due to
his role in secret Invasion I think he
might end up becoming a scroll and this
will be a big twist we know that
Harrison Ford is going to be taking over
foreign
MCU and in the Thunderball studies gonna
be the president that's just a bit of a
dude
but they do need to explain why there's
a new president and having one who's a
general would make sense since the
Scrolls pose such a security risk now
early on we get another news ticker and
this talks about Scotland touring the
buck a lookout for the little guy a
reading of this is coming up in Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania which will
end up bailing off the back of this
anyway a war between the Surface world
and talocan is start off with the
mourners forces attacking the U.S ship
this is shot almost like a horror movie
and it pulls a lot of iconography from
The Buckner more the depths in that he
attacks a submarine and hunts divers in
the dark similar to what happens here
when they carry out the Expedition back
in wakanda we get several cool little
Easter eggs including a water drummer
played by jibari Exum this guy is
actually a movement coach that works for
Marvel and he held to choreograph the
fight scenes for this film and also the
last one part of jabari's training
involved drumming away whilst actors
carried out their Moves In order to
create a rhythm and this is why they
picked him to play a water drummer in
the film no one sure he's taken out by
ramonda we can see elephants and these
animals have complex morning rituals the
animals possess empathy and they bury
their dead and even hold funerals for
the ones that they've lost similar to
the burning of the ropes after nemour
shows up to wakanda they convene the
council and we see him Baku walking in
he is eating a carrot and in the first
movie he said I'm kidding we are
vegetarians now in that movie they
didn't have a seat on the council but
now they do after t'challa welcome them
down from the mountains here we learn
this is all connected to Riri Williams
AKA ironheart and though I'm a bit meh
on her costume at the end there is a
nice little detail that they did in the
final one her name is of course iron
hard and they made it so that her
shoulders make a heart symbol when she's
wearing it I actually love her first
costume and when she's ripping off the
blueprints from her board we can see the
ones called The Mark 1 prototype this
initial flight is is of course very
similar the one that Tony took in his
Mark II and there are moments in it that
clearly refund things Tony's done both
scenes of them flying upwards which
causes issues with their ability to fly
and they both end with him crashing down
to the ground we even end up getting a
similar scene at the end to the one in
Infinity War when Tony blasts into the
sky also I love how akoye calls the
iPhone primitive
is that an iPhone I see primitive
now speaking of crappy costumes we get
the midnight Angels wand but these are
pretty comic book accurate so don't kick
off at me yet I didn't like it back then
either akoy ends up being strip of her
rank after that sweet sweet fight scene
on the bridge and then she ends up
creating this group later on in a nice
bit of attention to detail EO ends up
wearing gold in her armor for the rest
of the movie because she's now the
General in a kaye's place shuri is then
captured and taken the talocan and this
has lots of nods in it to Aztec culture
this includes the game pessapalo and
this involves hitting a ball through a
hoop which we can see lining several
structures another detail that you might
notice here is that the Tallow Canyons
don't have blue skin upon reaching
oxygen-rich environments their skin
color changes just in the same way that
blood goes from Blue to Red now at this
point ramonda ends up going to Nakia and
her War Dog past is mentioned in the
comics this was an intelligence agency
used by wakanda to scout the rest of the
world kelmunga's father was one of these
and this led him to his Oakland mission
that start off the first movie they use
covert tactics and this is why Nakia
later done to disguise complete with a
classic clock and glasses trick so that
no one recognizes it now if you're
enjoying the video we'd massively
appreciate the thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this every day we also have Eclipse
Channel with smaller Easter eggs and
highlights of movies and TV shows and
that'll be linked as the pinned comment
spam Mower and more shows shuri a whole
new world you also see his artwork and
these paintings only exist on the land
because he obviously can't paint
underwater now one thing that you might
not notice about the text in subtitles
is that they're golden for wakanda or as
for the Tallow Canyons they're always
blue the herb itself is also blue and
this leads the people into the water no
more is a mutant and much like the
comics he is one of the first he learned
this from Professor X originally and
he's represented both Atlantis and the
mutants in the source material Nemours
build a gigantic Empire and later on he
drops his catchphrase Imperial Rex oh
now if you try and say this from Latin
it means Empire King and it's set as a
war cry in the comics to anyone who
dares to defy him Nakia launches a
rescue mission and upon being picked up
we seize the grouper pulled up into a
ship through the use of a tractor beam
now this is also how t'challa's casket
is lifted at the start of the movie
during the first black panther t'challa
fell from a huge height and survived and
there is the potential that this tractor
beam was used at this point to help slow
its descent now Judah Nikia killing some
of his people the mall launches an
attack on wakanda and there's a really
subtle moment that hints at this
incoming assault when Nikki is talking
to akoye if you look at the ground under
the archway you can actually see that
the water is slowly stunned to come in I
love this little bit in the scene and it
foreshadows the big incoming attack now
this balls directly from the comics and
in The Avengers vs X-Men run nemour
ended up unleashing a tidal wave on the
entire nation romonda ends up dying and
she does this while saving Riri now
whilst all this is going on we have the
US government in the background who are
planning to go to war with wakanda
Everett Ross says that it's a bad idea
and this is similar black panther volume
4 issue 1. eventually shuri gets a suit
and shows up to the Jabari tribe she
comes in from the sky and as she lands
we can see her legs getting a purple
glow to them which is the suit absorbing
the kinetic energy of this impact this
is reflected in the fight with them all
and every time he hits her we see a
flash of purple and the troops man up we
get some great green screen and it leads
to all-out war on the ocean Sherry
creates hand cannons within the suit and
this is of course a call back to her
doing it in their first film now as she
skims along the side of the ship you can
see the spark she's creating are so hot
that they're burning blue instead of
orange this is because of the heat
required a cut vibranium and you know
what I think it's a really nice detail
assurians are pretty much boiling the
more alive and this is in order to
evaporate the moisture within his body
she rips off one of his little chicken
wings but he stabbed so with a spear
similar how killmonger was taken out in
the Pryor movie she breaks free though
and uses fire to take no more out which
is of course the opposite element to
water this was well shattered in the
throne room with the water no more
brought in being an opposite to the fire
killmonger create fire represents chaos
but sure he manages to rein it in after
seeing a vision of her mother the more
sees a vision of his mother too and we
know that she loved the service World
which is why he returned her body there
upon her death he's reminded that the
surface isn't really his enemy and that
they can find common ground which ends
the battle now I have seen some
confusion over the trial at the
waterfall but this does leave him Baku
as being the king in the first movie we
watched a ritual like this playing out
and t'challa only had to defend the
kingdom because he was challenged as the
challenges and met here mboku gets to
become the king and hey I'm down give
the man the throne I'm sure he goes to
burn her brother's robes and as Ramona
said earlier in the film burning of the
funeral Rogan marks the end of the
morning period in the beginning
of a new relationship with our loved
ones this new relationship with a loved
one that has passed is of course
represented in t'challa's son sure he
didn't know about him until now but
burning the rubs creates a new
relationship with her brother as she now
gets to help raise his child it's a sad
Ensemble way to end the movie and that
closes out our wakanda forever breakdown
hope you enjoyed it and as I mentioned
up top this is just more of the Obscure
details and links to the comics that we
haven't seen mentioned in other videos
if you want to see myself breakdown then
definitely go check out Ryan Aries video
in the movie which you know come on guys
that that was nice I told you to go see
Ryan Erie shut the up Ryan Airy
damn hey Greg man anyway that's that's a
video and if you want something else to
watch then check out our Brighton of
tour which will be linked on screen
right now lots of cool little details in
it that Jared goes through bit by bit so
definitely head over there right after
this by the way thanks for sticking
through the video I've been poor I'll
see you next time take care peace